los socialdemócratas están un paso más
cerca de formar el nuevo gobierno alemán
su líder olaf scholz se muestra
optimista en formar una coalición con
los verdes y los liberales guido órganos
braga harmon tan austral que los
ciudadanos nos dieron la tarea de
gobernar juntos añadieron su vez muy
intenso es cuestión de formar un
gobierno que quiera traer el progreso a
alemania y la necesaria modernización un
gobierno que quiera abordar la
modernización industrial y económica de
alemania que asegure que el cambio
climático impulsado por el ser humano
sea frenado y que asegure un mayor
respeto en nuestra sociedad ningún
partido obtuvo la mayoría absoluta en
los comicios generales lo que
intensificó las negociaciones tanto los
socialdemócratas como la unión
cristianodemócrata de la canciller
angela merkel han intentado sumar a su
causa a verdes y liberales y la balanza
parece inclinarse a favor de los
primeros ejemplares en su frenesí jane
complete ansa
no es un rechazo absoluto a una unión
con los conservadores han hecho un gran
esfuerzo sin embargo hay grandes
diferencias entre nosotros y por eso les
propusimos a los liberales acercarnos a
los socialdemócratas
e incluso la actual canciller parece
hacerse a la idea de que el candidato de
su partido a armin la 7 no gobernará el
fp de el spd y los verdes han celebrado
reuniones cruciales para discutir la
formación de gobierno hoy harbín laset
ha dicho que la cdu desea formar el
próximo gobierno pero la cdu no tuvo el
mejor éxito electoral y creo que no será
así el jueves está prevista otra reunión
entre el spd los verdes y los liberales
son momentos cruciales sobre el futuro
de la primera economía de europa que
podría dejar atrás a los conservadores y
pasar a manos de la izquierda tras 16
años del liderazgo de angela merkel